hey now this is a video request a lot of
you guys asked me hey Daniel what are
the best shoes for men and so in this
video that's what I'm gonna talk about
and there are a lot of different kinds
and styles of shoes there are eight
basic kind of shoes out there like
athletic shoes business shoes work shoes
sandals loafers outdoor shoes and so on
now we're going to look at all of these
shoes so let's get into the video
hey guys welcome to D LM model lifestyle
I'm Daniel and if you're new to my
channel please subscribe and click the
notification bell so that you won't miss
any new videos and I just say you know
I'll add the links of all the shoes that
I'm gonna talk about in this video in
the video description down below so it's
just a bit easier for you to go and
check them up now I've done a lot of
modeling jobs with a lot of shoes over
the last 12 years and there were some
shoes that are really great and some not
so much
for shoes to be really great they need
three basic things that kinda comes
together style meaning the way that they
look and then they need to feel really
good as well
and then lastly the quality needs to be
really good those three things are very
important and then the price of the
shoes needs to go together with those
three things if a shoe misses one of
these qualities it is not worth it to
buy it well that's my opinion at least
and hey I know that you might not agree
with me on all the shoes that I'm gonna
talk about in this video and that's fine
because we all have different styles and
with that in mind let's start we're
gonna start with athletic shoes now my
second choice is that adidas laced on 16
right now it goes for around one hundred
and seventy dollars and the word lace
tongue is a german word that actually
means performance and this shoe was
designed for Olympic weightlifters so
it's a great idea to take these shoes to
the gym you can get it in white or black
color but my first choice is the mecca
for shoes from the night well right now
they go for one hundred and thirty
dollars but that might change but it's
on you watch this video
this youth uses the natural
filled with explosive performance and it
comes in a big variety of colors that
you can choose from my favorite sneakers
is the white sneakers from Lanvin right
now they go for around four hundred and
ninety dollars which is a lot yeah they
are pricey but they are worth it if you
have the money now these shoes are made
in Italy from pristine white leather and
said unsupportive rubber soles the
issues fits in with almost everything a
man's got in his closet but if you are
on a lower budget and looking for
cheaper shoes try the white sneakers
from hmm actually I have them on I have
them on right now
this is how they look like these are
very comfy it's not expensive now they
sell between 20 and 30 dollars which is
not expensive at all they look and they
feel great as well
all right next is boots now my second
option for my favorite boots is that
Brown Chelsea boots in suede from ASOS
it goes for around fifty six dollars now
these boots scream style but my first
option is the Calvin Klein black men's
clark boots they go for around $80 and
they also come in a toffee color if that
is a color that you might prefer all
right now let's move on to formal shoes
now my second option for formal shoes is
Cole Haan worn kaptur Derby now these
shoes will never go out of style so
they're definitely worth the investment
and they also have four different colors
that you can choose from but my first
option is the LA Milano men's double
monk strap shoes these shoes is just
something else they go for around fifty
six dollars and they are one of the few
pairs of shoes on Amazon that gets the
full five-star from customer reviews I
thought of them in the link as well so
you can go and check them out yourself
and do a little bit of research now
let's move on to slip ons and the
loafers
[Music]
now my first option is the Santoni Fiske
square solo for that is made in Italy it
comes in black and brown color and it
goes for around five hundred and seventy
five dollars yeah it is a little bit
expensive but my second option is the
Dell Brook Italian leather loafer from
Banana Republic they go for around one
hundred and forty eight dollars so if
you're looking for a cheaper shoe that
is still great go and check them out now
if you're even on a lower budget my
third option is from all those all those
Maximillian City loafers now they go for
around forty five dollars which is a lot
cheaper and although has a huge variety
of loafers so if you want the loafers
while working with a low budget all
those should have a pair of shoes that
will work for you all right let's move
on to the sandals my first option for
the best sandals is the sandals from
Cole Haan
they're called the zero grande sandals
not only do they look and feel great but
the quality is good as well they have a
good rating wherever you look even on
Amazon they have a 4.5 gold stars from
customer reviews now they also come in
six different colors that you can choose
from my second option is the native
shoes
Spencer Alec I especially like the white
color that fits in with most clothing
styles but they also have three other
colors that you can choose from next
let's go to the outdoor shoes
all right the other shoes my first
option is the Salomon ex altra 3 GTX
hiking shoes because it has a perfect
mix of durability lightness and
performance now they come in 7 different
colors that you can choose from my
second option is the King Targhee 3
waterproof hiking shoes this is a great
update that modernized the classic tarji
design and it is one of the most popular
day hiking shoes out there alright now
let's move on to the best worker or
safety shoes alright now my second
option for the best
worker shoes is that Timberland Pro
men's Titan soft OH
leisa it has all three qualities style
comfort and quality this guy also has
one of the best customer reviews
everywhere but my first option is keen
utility men's atlanta cool steel so it
works you that comes in three different
colors this shoe is also rated at the
top everywhere you look
so you can go and check out the thousand
three hundred customer reviews just on
Amazon alone if you're unsure all right
now remember I've added the links of all
the shoes in a video description down
below just to make it a bit easier for
you to go and check it out under your
own research and hey I'd actually like
to know your favorite pair of shoes you
know every guy's got that one pair so go
ahead and add it in the comment section
down below now if you liked the video
give it a thumbs up subscribe and click
the notification belt so you won't miss
the next video and that's it cheers guys
you